it's gun week now the founding fathers
understood that only an armed people
could truly be a free people so this
week I invite you to join me in mug
clubs resident gun Aficionado Mr guns in
here as we tackle the subject of
firearms from every angle possible in
today's episode let's examine and debunk
some of the most egregious technical
myths regarding firearms and how they've
become so pervasive it's the fourth of
July and Firearms are as American
as I guess the American flag they're
very American you know what I think
that's a good thing you can hit the like
button if you like the fact that the
United States fought off the world's
greatest superpower one century only to
become the world's only superpower The
Next Century for all of its flaws uh and
this is installment number two of most
common gun myths that you hear we wanted
to separate them into two categories
because we have Mr guns and gear here
highly recommend that you go check out
his channel check out his content uh he
knows uh he he's forgotten more about
Firearms than I'll ever know I think is
the expression it's been a long day I'm
good with it and I'm distracted by his
his Chrome domius shine you have to well
you know we put on some powder we did
you don't wear sunscreen I don't you
refuse to wear sunscreen I do when we
were out at the range if uh you went and
watched the ballistics video we were all
Delirious because we had lost probably
about 10 pounds of water that day yeah
it was hot it was it was legit hot well
you're surrounded by burning tires in a
valley in Texas no wind so we wanted to
specifically get into now more of the
technical myths that you may hear about
Firearms as opposed to sort of
constitutional um Mist that you might
hear or lack therein as far as
constitutional application this is more
what you might hear about firearms that
might scare you away from um guns in
general uh and uh this Brink we'll do
seven maybe plus one in there uh myth
number seven that you've probably heard
quite a bit and run into is the AR-15 is
a weapon of war that was intended only
for military use the issue the following
statement they said our father Eugene
Stoner designed the AR-15 at subsequent
M16 as a military weapon to give our
soldiers an advantage over the AK-47 he
died long before any mass shootings
occurred but we do think he would have
been horrified and sickened as anyone if
not more so by these events and they
went on to tell me that he personally
although he was an avid shooter and an
Outdoorsman never owned the AR-15 his
key invention he never used it for
personal defense I've held an AR-15 in
my hand I wish I had it it is as heavy
as
10 boxes that you might be moving
and the bullet that is utilized a 50
caliber these kinds of bullets uh need
to be licensed and do not need to be on
the streets the truth Mr gear of wealth
uh the R15 is a derivative of the AR-10
which was designed first uh contracts
military contracts were awarded for that
uh to Cuba uh Sudan as well as others
but then the AR-15 uh was specifically
was uh labeled commercially the Colts
Porter so that was available to
civilians right and then of course the
M16 and there were some early variants
as well
um but into the m16a1 that was adopted
by the Army right yeah it was Mark you
know the M16 was basically available for
it was being pushed for military
contract and the AR-15 was
simultaneously being pushed as a
civilian firearm for sporting or hunting
right and initially they had much much
more success with the civilian sales
right than they did the military uh the
Air Force adopted what we
we would consider excuse me a M16 prior
to the Army but very small numbers so
for years the majority of AR-15s being
made were going to the civilian Market
only right
um well I think that one is a
let me consider that myth cooked and by
the way a reason that they're so popular
we'll get into this more later on is
that AR-15s are um they're they're
popular because they're versatile
they're easy to handle you can go back
to long guns 101. there's a reason that
they are popular and it's not because uh
they should be used only by Navy Seals
as a scary Black Rifle it's because it's
very easy for people who are
inexperienced Shooters to handle and hey
that's important if people are trying to
get a firearm that is controllable for
them especially when we're trying to
bring new folks into the community right
something that's lightweight easy to
shoot well easy to hit what you're
aiming at right it's the perfect weapon
for a lot of scenarios I've never had
anyone shoot in AR-15 who was a new
shooter and not find it one of the
easiest Firearms to shoot once they get
past the sound agreed but that's any
rifle like that right that's firing
around that quickly especially when you
compare it to a shotgun that Joe Biden's
recommending yes you don't need an AR-15
it's harder to aim it's harder to use
and in fact you don't need 30 rounds to
protect yourself buy a shotgun I mean in
all seriousness for a new shooter to be
able to proficiently handle a shotgun is
difficult right not so with the AR-15
well that's just a rule of kinetic
energy that correct you understand like
I haven't fired many double barrel
shotguns but I fired pump shotguns and
that alone is far more recoiling than
for example a semi-automatic shotgun
because part of that energy is used to
cycle the next round right or even a
pump action shotgun uh the biggest
malfunction or the most common
malfunction people have is called short
shocking where essentially they don't
run the action hard enough right you
have to do that after every round air 15
you don't right yeah it's one of those
things every single woman I've taken
goes wow that is surprisingly easy to
shoot because they're thinking uh well I
guess I believe what they've been told
that it's this unbelievable unwieldy
rifle and it couldn't be further from
the truth which brings us to another
this one's a fun myth you you were
laughing we were going over this myth
number six I don't know how common it is
but I have run into people who believe
it and we certainly know that former
Vice President Biden believes it the
myth is that nine millimeter uh blows
the lung out of the body
a nine millimeter bullet blows the lung
out of the body
okay here's the truth
uh
no no
it's simply not true yes
we'll we'll get into it more but um
incorrect yes completely but uh I I mean
okay I should clarify it would be
possible uh for maybe a portion of one's
lung to be carry I mean if you're if for
if it's like if two babies get into a
gunfight that might be possible Right
but a grown adult the idea that a nine
millimeter would blow along out of a
body this is someone again who
it's either gross incompetence or it is
um absolute dishonest I'll give you
concrete evidence for that uh Tupac was
shot in the lung and had to have it
surgically removed afterwards and he was
shot with a nine millimeter really yes
so his lung was still in his body right
and had to be removed afterwards well so
there you go if Joe Biden was right here
they could have skipped a step indeed
indeed it would have already been out
and here's something else too that I
think you you should know about look the
nine millimeter as a matter of fact so
nine millimeter has become uh ubiquitous
it's become far more popular what we say
would we say that it sort of um took the
place of other calibers after that the
famous Miami uh shootout in 1986 Miami
shootout in 1986 Miami shootout where
before that police officers were often
carrying either revolvers often in 357
yep right or um they would carry often
that colt 1911s you know thing variants
they're in which would be 45 correct now
to be clear uh both a 357 Magnum and a
45 ACP are Sig
people will argue with my but okay on
paper significantly more powerful rounds
357 for sure for sure it's an argument
and 45 obviously people will say with
modern ballistics it's more comparable
but it's a much heavier bullet traveling
historically 45 357 these are seen as
more powerful rounds nine millimeter uh
sort of became the the the round of
choice because it is effective enough
while still being controllable and can
be in a package that would be a you know
that could include a capacity like for
example a Glock a Walther some of the
modern Firearms Sig just got a military
contract my preference is Walter thanks
to them for sponsoring the studio
um or you have something that's
controllable effective enough kind of
minimum effective dose right and it also
has minimal recoil as well yes so you
can get your follow-up shots faster so
with handguns we talked about
incapacitation in the previous video and
with handguns you don't want to count on
a One-Shot stop because it's highly
unlikely you want to put as many rounds
On Target as quickly as possible until
the threat stops essentially so nine
millimeter allows you to do that easy
easier than the other cartridges simply
because they have more recoil right and
I think this seems like remedial I know
we'll have people in the car and believe
me I understand where you're coming from
and I appreciate you uh if you're a
firearm Enthusiast when everyone knows
that nine millimeter doesn't flow but
not everybody knows that a lot of people
have only heard nine millimeter referred
to in you know hip-hop songs about
violence and they hear nine millimeter
and they think that it's this show I
mean right played GoldenEye as a kid I
thought that uh the Golden Gun which I
think was just a Luger if I'm not
mistaken I'm not sure I don't know but I
thought that was the most powerful the
most powerful gun in existence and
unfortunately in a lot of other
countries as well nine millimeter is
banned because it's a quote-unquote
military cartridge so a lot of people
have that perception as well like
there's a lot of countries that 380 is
very popular for civilian use because
nine millimeters banned and I'll get
them in my comments saying oh nine
millimeters so much more powerful than
other rounds and I'm like what are you
talking about but that's where it comes
from you'll run into people like that
they'll say no one needs uh an AR-15 or
they'll say I've heard people say no one
needs a nine millimeter right just do
you have any idea how much more lethal
buck shot is from a 12 gauge and a 9
millimeter it's not even close I mean
it's yeah it's essentially eight nine
nine nine millimeters at once almost
they're slightly smaller but it's pretty
darn close right and so we'll say well
it's round as we get it the point is
it's it's like at least a handful of
nine millimeters coming out this idea
that a shotgun is controllable no the
idea that it's not as lethal at close
range it could very easily be argued
it's the most lethal of common of common
Firearms within 25 yards no doubt on a
shot for shot basis correct 12 gauge is
the most absolutely it's just that
you're most familiar with it and so they
want to keep you disconnected they want
to keep you unfamiliar with it they want
nine millimeter to be something that's
scary off in the distance your double
barrel or pump uh pump shotgun 12 gauge
shotgun is far more deadly far more
difficult to control and certainly more
scary to a home Intruder so that's why
there's nothing wrong with it if you
like your pump shotgun go ahead and keep
it I don't recommend shooting it into
the air yeah I think you have to do it
off your porch if I remember correctly
yes that is the recommended technique
yes isn't it funny it's like hey hold on
a second when we talk about you know
these surreptitious recordings it's like
well um former Vice President Biden
advocated a crime literally on camera as
advice it could be multiple crimes too
depending on where you live not just
firing the gun but firing it in a
residential area yeah in the air right
it has to come down yes it's not the
Middle East no uh and this brings us to
another myth and we did the ballistics
video which you can click the link and
go watch that
um you hear this a lot I don't
I I don't want to throw him under the
bus but even pops Crowder believed this
uh when I was young and I grew up he
said well you know what actually that
the 22 will bounce around the skull like
a ping pong ball because it's so um
small and uh here's the truth
no now that it wouldn't really matter if
you didn't have some people I've had
people then follow up with that's why I
carry a 22 right because I pointed at
their face and it's going to be like a
passport you're like that's not enough
right no I I don't know where it comes
from uh whether or not it was because uh
the mob like to use silence 22s for
certain hits or something like that I
have no idea but it's absolutely not
true the 22 performs like every other
bullet just smaller and lighter
um but yeah there's no bouncing around
they can curve they can yaw
um but bounce no yeah there's no
bouncing or sometimes what people will
refer to is they can tumble which means
you know if it goes in it might do a
little bit of do a little bit of this
action I don't know how much you can I
don't have a monitor see on camera or
does a little bit of this but any any uh
any bullet can do that correct and
they'll do it more in fact right larger
calibers but a lot of people believe it
let me ask you and comment below did you
believe that one a lot of people did and
then did you ever just go through the
basic
the basic Noggin test we go hold on a
second okay basically there's brain
think of a bunch of jello in your head
right and then some solid depending my
case is mostly Jello and it's bouncing
off a skull which would be moist so it's
not that much of sort of a Ricochet you
know a ricocheting surface and it would
bounce back through Jello and you know
relatively hard matter back again it of
course it makes no sense and it defies
physics but you have a lot of people who
believe it and that's because of
sometimes in a rash such an irrational
fear of firearms that people choose to
believe myths because they don't want to
be bothered to do research right it's
also a funny one it is it is but it's uh
yes completely debunked and something
else I guess that we could probably
touch on at this kind of uh same point
in time the myth that well actually a 22
is the most deadly round and you know
that because at some point in time there
were more deaths from uh the 22 than
other calibers and that's just because
it was the caliber that most people had
right 22 is still extremely popular and
probably I don't have the data on this
I'm making it up but up until two or
three decades ago it was probably the
most common caliber in America in terms
of firearms owned yeah I mean because
everyone gets a 22 to either do like uh
Critter maintenance you know you have
Critters around the house that you don't
want or you want to train your kid or
you want to cheaply hunt and there's a
lot of small game that can be hunted
effectively with 22 so I know a lot of
people I know grew up like literally
walking the woods with a 22. yeah so
yeah I mean today I don't know if it
would be enough considering that you
know you have people uh
I mean there are drag shows for kids my
point is you have no idea what's lurking
around the woods at this point you're
I'm not so much worried about
four-legged animals I'm worried about
you know if you see a paneled van I
would say you know nine millimeter or
higher yeah I agree with that
don't take it that seriously YouTube all
right uh something else this came from
actually Nancy and she's a very very
smart woman sure but we just sort of
compiled these from what people here
actually believed and she had heard this
is myth number four that uh the 22
caliber has a lot or disproportionate
number of spontaneous firing then it's
more likely to accidentally discharge
have you run into this a lot of people
believe in that I've heard it
um I don't think there's any truth to it
at all the only way that I could think
it might have proliferated is that there
just was more 22s right but other than
that no uh 22 for folks that don't know
is a Rimfire cartridge so most of the
cartridges we're talking about are
center-fired meaning they have to be
struck in the center of the back of the
cartridge whereas 22 doesn't but I can't
see how being a Rimfire cartridge would
cause a discharge yeah what is true is
typically because it's rim fire red it's
easier to mass produce and so you end up
with a significantly lower quality ammo
that is absolutely true so this could
maybe be true if in a fit of frustration
from having another uh
non-discharging at all 22 which is very
common you smack your piece of crap gun
saying and it accidentally discharges
yeah maybe but that is true with
rimfire's uh a lot of well there's a lot
of reasons I don't recommend rent buyers
for self-defense but that is one of them
they're definitely less reliable in
terms of ignition of the powder we were
pretty surprised with the uh the
ballistics results with that we had a 22
that penetrated 16 inches out of a
pistol and and tumbled a little bit yeah
kind of a surprising wound chance very
surprising so Federal makes a round
called punch 22 which is designed for
that very use and they charge a ton of
money for it it's super expensive and it
performs just like that so to see that
with just common I'm gonna find out what
that was yeah I feel like it was very
old like from the 80s or something uh
Super X Winchester Super X were being
told is what it was so we cannot confirm
nah just to be clear but all of us I
think I think we were like was that 22
magnum yeah is that just a basic really
was it like a I think are these the Mini
Mags or something and then we're like no
it's just an old someone went let me
check
like The Neverending Story blew off the
dust it was like oh no it's just these
yeah I don't want to disparage it but
not too impressive I guess to people in
the know there you go there you go
um okay here's a myth
that you really wanted and we you'd
think it would be done with the
ballistics uh test that we did I'd
recommend go click that video and I'm
sorry I love him he's a great but Brian
Callan believes this one right and it's
because and you know that someone said
someone told him who was former special
forces that part of course said all you
need and this is myth number three all
you need for home defense is bird shot
but I didn't know that if you're
defending your hole with a shotgun the
formula dictates that you're supposed to
buy both boxes this was not a formula
that I was familiar with it goes like
this the six shots in 12 gauge shotgun
so when you load the gun you load it
like this first shot burnt shot next
shot Buckshot first shot and then after
that guns Jamaican Buckshot Buckshot
buckshot
how often do you hear people say that
all the time and I'll just go out there
on a limb and say special operators
rarely using bird shot right it's just
not a thing yeah
um but yeah people do say it all the
time and one of the things that they
recommend it for is a lack of
quote-unquote over penetration uh for a
home defense type scenario like I.E you
don't want your bullets to go through
the walls into your neighbor's house or
something like that right and to be fair
I don't want that either it's not going
to over penetrate because it's not even
going to penetrate yes
so uh I think the gel test we did the
pellets were between three and six
inches yeah total like six was Max and
that wasn't a lot of them
um and that's gel test you know you're
not even
keep in mind like the front jacket it
looked like a sesame seed Bagel
literally yeah literally so yeah
um the FBI recommends anywhere between
12 to 18 inches of penetration for
Reliable quote-unquote stops
um and yeah it's obviously nowhere near
that not even close and I argue often
um that if you're talking about
penetration and what you actually want
for most shooting scenarios particularly
civilian shooting scenarios I.E not law
enforcement or not military
um you want to error on the side of a
little bit more penetration uh than a
little bit less reasons for that people
are getting fatter number one there's
that it's very real you have to
penetrate further to hit the vitals
um and then gosh if you look at uh just
now I'm gonna say figuratively but like
half the Victoria's Secret models I
probably wouldn't even feel bird shot
right literally it wouldn't reach any of
their organs at all no and it's sad but
it's true yeah I mean think about what
have you guys actually seen fat when
they just actually show you fat we did
that in high school I don't know if they
do that yeah this is what five pounds of
fat looks like this with five pounds of
muscles it's very similar to the
ballistics gelatin the bird shot would
very easily get caught in six inches of
fat yep for sure
um yeah so there's just I highly
enclosed too right
heavy jackets depending on where you
live right um I mean they're stories of
confirmed stories from uh the Korean War
where the Chinese jacket stopped some of
the 30 cow bullets stopped being shot by
American soldiers yeah um so that's a 30
caliber bullet we're not talking about
bird shot you know what I mean what's
birdshot gonna do it's not even it's not
gonna get close clear I hate to do this
no one here is saying that their jackets
were bulletproof no okay what we are
saying is that it added complications if
they had winter coats they had those
jackets which were very you know tightly
the correct effects and most of those
were M1 carbines to be clear which is a
not very powerful round for a rifle and
there's distance involved so the bolts
weren't going fast right there's there's
facts we're not saying it no so if what
we're saying is it didn't penetrate deep
enough to cause the kind of wound that
you would need to cause the soldier to
stop cause a soldier to stop just
because you know people are going to try
to I know I shouldn't have brought that
up no but you're no I understand exactly
what you're talking about uh and uh this
is one of those things too the bird shot
so we have these numbers we had several
portions of bird shot only going three
inches the majority of it yeah the
majority of it it's from the ballistics
video which I think we're playing for
you now is uh the average is six inches
and then with 12 gauge when you're
talking about uh Buckshot uh 21 inches
that's a significant difference and
that's double a buck shot to be clear so
right for folks that don't don't know
double Hot Box shots typically large
projectiles for shotguns they make other
Buckshot loads like they make a number
one buck shot and then number four buck
shot as well which are smaller but still
have that buck shot effect of
penetration so if somebody's looking at
that number of average of 21 inches
let's say and they're like oh that's a
lot of penetration I'm not comfortable
with it I recommend going down to either
number one buck shot you're going to
take on average uh two to three inches
of penetration off number four will take
about another two to three inches of
penetration off and still give you good
lethality yeah and not risk what what we
saw with bird shot why do you think this
is so good this is one that is very
common I can't tell you how many people
have said yeah I just keep birds shot in
my shotgun is extremely common that's
fantastic for home defense yep why do
you think it's so common
I I think it's people number one not
understanding ballistics there's that
yeah
um and then people use it Todd birds and
birds die and they're like oh that must
work well on people and that's just not
the same guy in the face in the face I
remember when I first heard that I
thought and I didn't know much about
Firearms back then and I've never been
bird hunting I thought oh well I guess
that guy's gone and it's it was really
more of a nuisance right he was fine he
apologized for diction he apologized to
Dick Cheney correct which I don't know
how that happened but when we were
talking about this uh we say yeah this
myth we're going in gingersnap who works
with us in research he said wait people
say bird shot is and he's from Kansas he
said my friend was shot with bird shot
and he can still mostly see out of that
eye oh yeah there's there's a video
online of a guy
breaks into a house and it's like
unfortunately it's a woman shoots him
with birdshot he at the time is maybe
five yards away he runs towards her
grabs a gun and hits her in the head
with it
um so he was completely yeah not
impacted by it at all and I know what
some people say well yeah I bet you
don't want to be stand in front of my no
one's saying that we want to be shot
with bird shot but add PCP to the mix
Right add some kind of a a thick coat
and by the way I do think that with
birdshot a few layers in a thick coat
but it'll stop it yeah it will which
would stop it
um I mean I used to cheat and paintball
where we would put on more so that it
wouldn't hurt so you'd feel Invincible
obviously paintball's not as as severe
as bird shot but it's not even close
just to be clear this is a very
pervasive myth birdshot is not an
adequate choice for home defense if you
disagree please comment below and uh
I'll like if you don't like that people
disagree yeah I was gonna say if you
disagree well then you're wrong yes
you're wrong there's to be clear there's
room to for example we were talking
about 380. yeah now some people argue
and I understand why they're both sides
of this with modern ammunition that you
can get a 380 in a hollow point that can
penetrate deeply enough to effectively
expand but historically there was a
strong case to be made and some still
can make it with 380 that using ball
ammo meaning basic basic ammo that is
not a hollow point is a better idea
because you run the risk of under
penetration there are discussions like
that that I think both sides have valid
points uh there is nothing valid about
bird shots or home defense I agree yeah
I agree unless you're being attacked by
Canadian geese and that does happen it
actually happens where I live a lot yes
one of my neighbor's kids was actually
mauled by a Canadian goose that's a
horrible way to go yeah so he's alive
but he had a bunch of uh plastic surgery
on his face well you know what's sad
yeah because they grab you they grab yes
and they they Shake yep that's the thing
it's people think well they don't have
teeth but it's like a vice grip and then
they they Shake yeah the sun was about
two it was not good you know what's
horrible with it Joe Lewis is even
afraid of them might my dog one time he
was running we were at a lake in
Oklahoma and he was running there were
three Canadian geese and he just kind of
ran up and then they all just spread
their wings they're like I didn't even
want to anyway and he ran off like but
he saved his face yeah right I'm good
yeah so keep one rifle for a Canadian
geese they're not in danger I don't I
don't think so shoot the Canadian geese
uh but it's something else for for
non-geeese related uh miscreants Peter's
gonna love that yeah exactly I don't
care and uh I mean we started on the
burrowing owl oh gosh you spend time in
Florida you know exactly yes I do all
right this brings us to myth number two
while we're on shotguns
um that you don't need to aim them to
Jill if there's ever a problem just walk
out on the balcony here or walk out put
that double barrel shotgun and fire two
blasts outside the house I promise you
who's ever coming in is not gonna you
don't need an AR-15 it's harder to aim
it's harder to use and in fact you don't
need 30 rounds to protect yourself buy a
shotgun
why shotgun there you go just I mean
first off that doesn't even really
necessarily apply the Biden clip
applying here it's just funny we want to
roll again but you know because if
you're firing in the air you wouldn't be
aiming at anything right uh maybe the
voice is in your head but but uh if you
are actually dealing with an attacker
it'll say aim it in the general vicinity
and I've heard this a lot and it's it's
fine do it from the hip right here that
like the old lady and but just point it
down the hallway right yes exactly
um the truth the truth is uh really
depends on the load you're using and the
type of shotgun but as a general rule
um sort of a baseline to go off of uh
Buckshot is going to expand in terms of
the group pattern at about one inch for
every yard right now you can change that
with different chokes uh you can change
it with different ammunition that's
designed to spread less or spread more
um but with a
it's called a cylinder bore which is
like your standard Remington 870 home
defense gun has with that you can expect
the spread of about an inch at every
yard which means that 10 yards which is
pretty far for a Home Defense Shooting
for a home defense it'd be pretty fun I
mean if you live in the house in The
Shining right exactly I mean that's
that's this much on your chest right and
that's at 10 yards so you definitely
have to aim yeah Not only would you have
to aim but again if you're talking about
the risk of you know walls obviously
you'd want to some could argue you'd
want to be more accurate to make sure
that you're not off center but this idea
that it's going to be
uh you remember when uh in in the old uh
Bugs Bunny I don't know how many times
I've referenced Bugs Bunny uh the old
cartoons was like the bees would turn
into one big giant bee and right that's
what a shotgun is like like at five
yards it's a stop sign no of death and
it's not even close and and honestly you
don't want it to be no so for lethality
uh you want them to be closer together
for sure that's why as I mentioned a lot
of people will add chokes and a choke
basically is just a screw-in device that
screws into the end of your barrel and
it forces the rounds to come together as
they exit
um so that way they stay in a tighter
pattern so a lot of people use that for
that very reason to keep them tighter
because a lot of cases that's what you
want home defense I would argue that's
what you want now to be fair going back
to the bird shot which we aside from for
Canadian geese uh that's a much wider
spread it is because there's so many
projectiles correct but again it also
depends on the joke as well right
depends but a typical bird shot let's
say at 10 yards compared to we'll shred
more that would be I mean if if Buck
Shot let's say would this be about fair
for buckshot like you were saying
something like that maybe a little a
little bit more at 10 yards what would
bird shot
yeah you're gonna add about might be a
stop sign about a third I'd say 33 at
least yeah but again it varies a lot by
the round you're using but it definitely
all things being equal which they never
are birdshot will spread more it doesn't
matter though because it's still just
burn shot correct who cares about that
uh oh you know what I guess oh okay we
do have a plus one in here all right uh
but first before that the number one and
this is one
look thanks to everyone who served their
country to be clear okay uh we
appreciate it
you are more of a man or a woman than
myself I mean I was raised in Canada so
I couldn't really serve here but thank
you however
this myth that we hear quite a bit is
that oh Mill spec means it's the best or
mil-spec means it's Superior where
sometimes it's just used it's used as a
marketing term correct it's used at a
marketing term but it's also a baseline
standard exactly that's really what it
is for military weapons and a lot of
folks like competitive shooters for
example that have these three thousand
dollar race guns they're always like
don't call my gun Bill spec that's trash
they get offended
um so but yeah mil spec is literally
what it says it's the military
specification for a given item right so
on the AR-15 it's the specification for
the barrel it's the specification for
the receiver it's specification for the
stock Etc
um so that's what mil-spec means now
um it can be a good Baseline if you
don't know anything and you buy
something that's middle spec quote
unquote
um you know at least it's been tested to
a certain standard right so I'm not
saying mil-spec's bad but it doesn't
mean that it's better than anything for
sure I mean it definitely doesn't well
you will get some people you know again
thank you to everyone but then you'll
get the sometimes people were referred
to as vet Bros like no no I only use
this mil spec and they'll make fun of
someone else wants I can actually like
you're saying that's the minimum
Baseline of quality but even by the way
some things that are mil-spec soldiers
in some cases especially Special Forces
they will level up and get something
that's better than basically I was just
about to say that so
um a lot of like take the AR-15 for
example a lot of the current changes
that are happening with uh the air
pattern guns and the military are coming
from the three gun world in the
competitive world so like uh for example
now they're adding longer hand guards
free-foot handguards to enable Shooters
to basically shoot them better yeah
proficiently and those are not mil-spec
but because they're being adopted by
units and being tested by units now uh
for example uh the latest one has been
the urgi which is the upper receiver
Improvement I believe is what it stands
for
um but I had a UTI yeah yeah just uh
drink some cranberry that's about to say
yeah so but I think it's another big
Ploy just just by big Ocean Spray so is
that a thing yeah it's big big cranberry
cranberry
but the urgi
um basically it's been adopted by lots
of military units now and all of the
influence on it has come from
competitive shooting just to make it
faster so the mil spec is
number one evolving
um and it's evolving because
sometimes not always there's better than
mil-spec so why not make that the new
middle spec right and what I just and I
don't necessarily know how standardized
it is where sometimes people will slap
it you know in a magazine app or
sometimes online
um where the point is don't just look
for that term and think that you have
your bases covered right there are some
there are some great Firearms out there
that wouldn't probably just list a
mil-spec and there's some not so great
Firearms up to be marketing themselves
and using the term mil-spec uh so that's
why we wanted to address that because
you will have some people say hey I know
mil-spec I also know birdshot
we have a plus one here but you know the
plus one is you should never dry fire
your weapon and I don't know that's
that's not true unless you have an older
school like revolver where it's a firing
pin right or Rimfire guns right or
Rimfire guns but this the plus one that
I wanted to address all right is it kind
of continuing on but it wasn't really
like a myth that's that pervasive but
you hear it a lot and it's stupid and it
bothers me
is uh this is just sort of I guess let's
call it the amalgament of a lot of these
other myths that then people become
married to where you'll hear for example
and this is with the military culture a
little bit say I carry my gun Israeli
stuff oh God here we go because if it's
good enough for the IDF it's good enough
for me now to be clear Israeli style
means carrying a handgun right with with
empty chamber empty chamber in a full
magazine and a full magazine meaning
before you get into some kind of uh a a
an active shooting scenario you would
have to Rack a slide
um now
it is technically true that they many as
members of the Israeli military care
this way but and many do not just to be
clear right and many do not
but the reason that it's even
permissible in that scenario just to be
clear is because a lot of people hear
IDF and again
thank you Jews for all that you do and
IDF like I get it somebody's going to
cut that clip thank you Jews
badass Jews we get it and by the way the
the Intel that they have is unbelievable
okay a lot of but you also have to
understand like we said with mil-spec
meaning a baseline of quality right
you know you do have people it's
mandatory right to go into the Israeli
military the reason that they have to
have someone carry an Israeli Style with
an empty chamber is because it's going
to be carried literally by Gal Gadot
not because it's the most effective way
to be ready for an armed conflict but
because you want to make sure that
people who have no business being in the
military and I don't know if she could
have been a great Soldier I have no idea
but there are plenty of people who have
no business being in the military who do
find themselves in the Israeli military
so it's look just carry it with an empty
chamber in the mag and the safety on
you're probably never going to use it
anyway and you know don't brush your
hair with it yeah for sure
um and I obviously carrying it that way
is better than not carrying anything
um but to assume that you're going to
have two hands available in a
self-defense situation is an assumption
I don't want to make right um because
it's very possible that you won't right
um so yeah not a big fan of IDF style
and to your point it's not recommended
because it's good right it's kind of
recommended because it's just super safe
right and everyone's afraid of the guy
with the gun this happens a lot for
people with liability right for example
these are other myths that you can make
like oh having your firearm and this
depends too if you get you get the wrong
judge in this country was your firearm
in a biometric safe here's the truth buy
a metrics right fingerprint safes some
of them are far easier to hack and Jimmy
open than uh than other forms of of well
other safes and by the way there's some
I don't know what you call those where
it's different like a speed like you
kind of have to hit certain things at
the same time it's not biometric but no
I know you're talking about though uh ah
anyway there's anywhere they're
different it's not a combination safe
but there are all kinds of different
safes out there that can be more
effective than a biometric safe for sure
but if you get a judge they'll say well
you have kids in the house or do you
have a biometric safe it doesn't mean
it's the most effective you have a lot
of these myths that are just pervasive
that we unfortunately sometimes use as
the foundation for Law and people
sometimes writing these laws have no
idea and some states do yeah exactly
past laws like that unfortunately
California has safe storage act there's
other there's other states that do as
well and I'm not saying you shouldn't
keep your firearms in your safe uh by
all means everyone's situation is
different everyone's children are
different Etc
um but
if you have a gun for home defense you
have to be able to access it right to
defend your home yes right so and the
quicker you can do it the better uh
somebody kicks your door and how long do
you have to access that gun right so
just keep that in mind well yeah so I I
I do have one of the Biometrics I have
several different safes but one of them
is a biometric safe and I found and this
is what you I actually showed it yeah it
might be considered one of the higher
end biometric States right it works
maybe 60 of the time and here's the
problem it works almost no percent of
the time if my finger is sweaty which is
very likely if someone's at the foot of
my bed with a balaclava at three in the
morning oh they're good yes I would
imagine there'd be some perspiration
yeah for sure yeah um biometric safes
are sketchy uh in terms of reliability
at this point maybe one day and uh I'm
not sure if you've seen it but they just
recently I mean like this month yeah the
first commercially available quote
unquote smart gun yeah we'll see how
that works out yeah I I have my uh
reservations are you saying it's more of
a perhaps a dumb gun yes
um
and that's a horrible place as horrible
of a place to end as any uh but so let's
do it yes uh we hope that this has
helped and by the way we make all the
references of course publicly available
you can go back to the catalog this week
thank you so much to uh Mr guns and gear
Mike for coming out go check out his
YouTube channel his content on mug Club
um none of this exists without you so do
consider joining up at louder with
crowder.com where you get additional
content additional shows and it allows
us to continue creating this kind of
information whether you can find it on
YouTube or not so go back and watch I
think we'll have chapters here handguns
101 long guns 101 covering rifles and
shotguns ballistics and then cultural
and historical political myths uh that
you might most commonly run into and hit
the like button I don't really even know
this the thing is this could be running
two or three years from now where the
like button doesn't even exist it's
entirely possible so they took the
dislike away for President Biden yes
they did yeah they did yeah but like the
like buttons next they replaced it with
just a double-barreled shotgun aiming at
the sky and you can hit it so they can
put you on a watch so we'll see you uh
in a little bit stay tuned here to this
channel um next week some specials
that'll be uh we'll be installing and
then of course we'll be back uh back
with the Regular Show uh after this
break thank you again
if you like this video click like
consider subscribing or comment below
and of course consider tuning in to the
live show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern right here on this channel